[Musique]
enfin de soutenir la production locale
de fruits et légumes les plus consommés
à la réunion le département le remplacer
subventions spécifiques aux agriculteurs
indépendants
à l'occasion de la 36ème édition des
hommes vers la collectivité a souhaité
faire le point sur son dispositif la
mamie change avec les agriculteurs
concernant alors l'aide dont on a parlé
ce matin c'est l'aide aux fruits et
légumes pour les producteurs
indépendants dont coup soutient en fait
on se production prioritaires comme la
porte de terre l'oignon l'ail la tomate
et ce dispositif a été mis en place en
2017 a été reconduit en 2010 neuf et a
concerné 422 agriculteurs pour à peu
près un million trois cent mille euros
pour le dispositif total en 2009
l'occasion pour les départements d'avoir
l'opinion des agriculteurs sur cette
subvention est d'analyser l'efficacité
du dispositif mais également l'addition
aux pistes d'amélioration pour 2020 un
pouvoir si ce qui s'est passé sur ces 3
et des années au niveau du département
ils ont mis en place des aides pour la
production locale pour pouvoir
concurrencer un peu les produits
d'importation
donc c'est un dispositif qui a
fonctionné doucement au départ et qui a
pris de l'ampleur au fil des années et
j'espère que cette ça sera reconduit des
années à venir parce que ça a permis à
pas mal d'agriculture de sortir la tête
de l'eau
et de mettre en place des cultures qui
se faisait pas auparavant genre à et
oignons et relancer ses cultures
c'est une grande importance lorsque ces
aides nous a été attribuée donc nous en
tant qu acteur et producteur donc de
légumes et qui s'était nous a été
bénéfique par rapport à la compensation
des prix ça nous permet à peine compensé
le prix et puis aide beaucoup
financièrement faut donc les rachats de
ce nom ce la replantation sachant qu'on
a traversé donc des périodes difficiles
de sécheresse du uta de fin de monde
donc ça nous a permis quand même de
faire des rachats de semonce et puis de
payer loup qui n'est pas de l'eau
d'irrigation parce qu'on est obligés
d'arroser avec de l'eau potable en fait
donc l'aide nous est très bénéfique et
ça porte un inconfort va dire dans la
trésorerie des tout au long de miel vert
le stand du département accueillent le
public et propose des questionnaires aux
agriculteurs mais aussi aux
consommateurs afin de toujours
accompagner au mieux la production
locale
[Musique]